kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odenson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's a family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
my um sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back
there he's just my first bad guy
you never forget your
[Music]
not like the first gods earth kill
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are and take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him mean eventually grape
[Music]
you